so i have some genuinely great news for
you today you know most of the stories
uh that we have when you do news and
politics are unfortunately stories of
people doing things we don't want bad
things happen things we have to resist
but here's a good story something that
we should welcome
uh and i'm doing the story knowing it's
not going to get a lot of clicks not
that many people care about it because i
care about it i think that this is good
the latino civil rights organization the
league of united latin american citizens
has officially dropped latinx as a
gender-neutral term for referring to
latino or hispanic individuals of which
i am one uh and the organization's
president domingo garcia sent out an
email last week saying we are stopping
the use of latin x in all communication
it's very unliked by most latinos and of
course that that's a factor that's
something that certainly should be
considered now there are a ton of
organizations still using it but one
organization saying we're not going to
use it anymore is a good thing and i've
been against this term for a while when
people have asked about it i've
mentioned it anecdotally but i've not
really done a segment about it as many
of you know
um i'm from argentina grew up speaking
spanish my mom teaches spanish
literature and language uh at the
college level has for decades um with my
family being from argentina and
politically involved as you can imagine
this idea of latinx particularly in the
united states is something that i've
been involved in you know a dozen hours
or more of discussion about over the
years i have been opposed to this term
for a number of reasons now first of all
spanish is different than english
and it
really makes no grammatical sense now i
know many but wait david hold on a
second sir
some people say referring to a trans
person as they makes no grammatical
sense if it's the right thing to do then
it's the right thing to do okay
first of all they singular actually
makes plenty of sense if you look at the
history of the english language people
actually use it even today all the time
without even realizing they're using
they to refer to one person
latinx is a completely different
category but it's not wrong that one
could argue
even if it makes no grammatical sense we
might say for reasons of justice and
equity
let's make it part of the language if
you want okay
we go to the next issue
the problem with latinx is that it did
not stem from a desire from within the
global latino community to change
language to be more gender inclusive or
gender-neutral latinx was pushed
primarily by non-latino people the
origins aren't a hundred percent clear
it might have been academic in origin it
might have come from the feminist
community there were a number of
professors in the us who at one point
argued for changing the term chicano to
chican x rather than chicano
and at the same time there might have
been some people said let's do the same
thing with latinx but the point is it
was mostly embraced
by non-latino people and in survey after
survey almost no latino folks actually
used the term or preferred it and many
didn't didn't even know what it was
um i once hosted an awards show
for a latino organization and on the
scripts they sent me for introducing
different awards it said latinx and i
said listen guys i don't speak that way
my audience knows i don't speak that way
it's going to be very obviously not
genuine
if all of a sudden i'm saying latinx and
they said okay don't use it and the ease
with which they just said don't use it
signaled to me
this may be going out at some point soon
so the point here isn't language can't
change over time of course it can
um we don't use the r word as an insult
i mean listen there are people that do
but it's
i cringe when i hear someone use the r
word as an insult we don't call people
or i don't the f word as an insult uh at
least many of us don't we don't say or i
don't that's gay when i want to say
something is bad
and that has sort of removed itself from
the culture
because the culture is what changed not
because it was suddenly said the word is
done there of course have been attempts
to say in a school setting or whatever
we don't use this word or we don't use
that word or here's the word that you
use but that's fundamentally my real
issue with latin x this was not
a cultural movement from within
whose natural conclusion was let's use
the term latin x rather than latino or
latina it was from above let's just
change the language
and then we'll fix the other stuff that
comes with it and of course we can deal
with issues of gender inequality gender
inequality within the latino community
etc without having to come in and say
this is now the word that is being used
so
i like that it was dropped in this case
i think it's a good thing i hope it goes
away completely i'm going to continue
not using the word while i fight and
argue for
all of the very things
that the words imposition
was theoretically
supposed to push
let me know your thoughts if you have
them i know for a lot of people this is
like not even really an issue at all uh
it's just not something you think about
something that's not it's not it's not
even in sort of the discussion for lots
of folks uh something i've been
following for a while and glad to see
the decision quite frankly